What's interesting to me today is the biggest subsidies in agriculture in terms of price - distorting subsidies...
...are in primarily Third World countries or Middle World countries.
In some cases, the countries that benefited most from Norman Borlaug's green revolution...
...were those that gave income security to their farmers,...
...which encouraged them to go out and deploy it.
And so I think one of the things that's misunderstood is the presumption...
...that the US and Western Europe are at this very moment the world's largest subsidizers of agriculture.
In point of fact, it's not the case. It's the other way around of people...
...with small-scale agriculture giving price support to their growers...
...in order to encourage real income distribution.
Countries like China that have an incentive to keep people employed in agriculture,...
...have subsidized their agriculture heavily.
India, the same.
Mexico, the same.
Zambia.
And so there are a lot of countries out there that in the name of rural income support...
...have put subsidization programs in place to achieve broader social purposes.
And so I think subsidies are something that are misunderstood...
...the way in which they are being utilized today.